(upbeat dance music)
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentleman, the Icon, Miss Tempress.
- If you've never been
through a transition,
you probably won't ever understand it.
You know, before we had
so many trans girls,
we didn't have a voice.
A lot of us were stealth.
And no matter how passable you look,
or whatever you've accomplished,
there's some type of doubt.
(cheering)
The Ballroom kind of gave
trans girls a family.
It was me being accepted by my peers.
And in Ballroom, bitch we're over the top.
- [Announcer] Here we go, I-C-O-N!
Tempress,
Icon.
- Face is really the
first thing that you see,
and so first impressions are lasting.
So Chasity is more laid back,
it's the every day chick.
Sometimes I just brush out and really not
put too much on.
But then Ballroom, I'm Tempress,
and I've been in this scene
for 20-something years.
I'm gonna give you like,
"Bitch, there's nobody else in here."
- [Announcer] This is now Battle Zone.
- You might be painted for blood,
but you don't really want
it to look like that.
Don't go overboard, you know,
just accentuate what you have.
- [Announcer] Ladies
and gentlemen, the Icon.
- In Ballroom, Icon is like,
you can't go any further.
When you walk and you win so much,
they start judging you against yourself.
I have my own legacy now.
I've started a house
with a few other people.
You know, as a mother,
I try to make things a
little easier for them.
Some of us start out as a caterpillar
and then you become that butterfly.
So I'm there to kind of
help that progress along.
- [Announcer] Judges, score
the Icon Tempress Margiela.
- But I'm definitely one
of the girls to beat.
They still are saying my
name for at least 22 years.
They're still saying,
"watch out for Tempress."
- [Announcer] Ten, ten,
tens across the board.